do something right now hello
and now we finally we finally got it we
finally got it all right this is it it's
working fine now okay
once again restart technical
difficulties but nobody needs to know
that ladies and gentlemen this is my
friend mr
bill burr co-founder of all things
comedy the network that i'm on
and here he is like you said happy
pandemic
yes how are you what's going on
uh you know i'm as good you know you
know it's funny when people ask you that
they go how you doing it's a weird
question because
the answer is always the same i'm eh you
know like i'm as good as i can be
in in the times that you know we're
living in i always feel like life is
like a scale
and then you take the pandemic and you
put it on one side so it's already
tipped this way and then and then like
so everything
your other stresses in life are also
going to go on top of that and make it
go like this
but you know it is what it is yeah
but you know i think they're starting to
do some uh
safe socially distancing shows so comics
can make a little bit of money
which is exciting um it's slowly opening
up i think people are wearing masks i
think the cases are going down i don't
watch the news i just sit around and
think
positive things and i say positive
that's how i do it yeah man i know i
know i know exactly what you're saying
just being as positive as possible now
you're frozen
like this is this is a this is a
nightmare i get the sound working oh
there you go
there you are there you are but this is
all good though we're gonna love this
this is all gonna be great for it
yeah cause i know you were at the
chappelle you went to the chappelle
summer boot camp you said that was your
first show in six months yeah i mean i
did
two um parking lot shows outside the
magic castle
um yeah yeah
those were pretty wild it was like
people in cars meets comedian who hasn't
done his act in five months so
rusty as hell a bit of a staring contest
uh they were very supportive the crowd
was great from what i could hear
they were great you know isn't it funny
though that like if i would have asked
you
seven months ago i said hey bill i got a
couple of shows
i'm putting on in the magic castle
parking lot
like your whole thought press a thought
process of how you would want to say no
the only one i mean it's so ridiculous i
might have done it for
for the goof just to do it like um
people are gonna be sitting in their
cars this is so ridiculous i have to do
it and now
it's like exciting like i'm gonna be
over there this weekend
i i you know i put my kids to bed and
then i go out and do a set i feel like a
man again like i'm working
yeah man i'm not making any money but
you know you're just sitting around like
uh
i don't know i i grew up with parents
who worked really hard and i like to
think i worked hard and i just been
feeling like a bump
dude i know exactly how you feel it's
like so my girl works
and so i like so she goes she was going
to work and the first part like that
when the pandemic started to like ease a
little bit and then
i just felt like who am i so i started
cooking and cleaning and doing all this
stuff just to feel like i have purpose
because they want oh no you have you got
to do that like if the other person is
working and you're not
you got to start doing the homemaker
[ __ ] um
unless you're a feminist and then you'd
never do it
which is so stupid like man or woman if
one of you is out there
working and the other one isn't then you
know i mean if my wife was out there
working my you know i would
my house would be spotless i would be i
would be old betty crocker
that's what that's how i feel man and
then like sometimes we would get into
these arguments
because she would be like wants to help
when she got and i'd be like no get out
of here
and she thought it was about her and i
was telling her no i want to do this for
you i need to feel like i'm doing
something because literally
we were doing comedy one day
and then the world felt like it ended as
a comedian
the next day and it hasn't restarted now
for six months
and now we're doing this in all honesty
[ __ ] shows
okay we're doing some [ __ ] shows to
make ourselves feel like we're still
normal
but i'll tell you i bombed on the first
one that i did coming back and it didn't
feel like a fake bomb
it felt like a real bomb and the next
night
i killed and i felt connected to the
crowd
so uh don't knock it till you try it i
have i've done a i did a okay
i did a drive-in show at the at the
spectrum in irvine
they had the rooftop and it was just all
cars but dude but i'm just being i'm
just being real about it like
i miss doing comedy like i didn't even
know who i
i don't even know who i am without
comedy and so i'm finding that out now
i'm finding out that i have to be more
than just a comedian more than just an
artist
you know so like when i was there i'm
looking at these cards be a homemaker
yeah
i know i'm looking at these cars man and
i'm looking at you could
hear laughter and people are honking in
the back and you just go i go
wow is this what i is this what it's
gonna be now
and it's just favorite savor it because
it's not what it's going to be now and
it's going to be this time in your life
imagine if this happened in 1980
from that era seinfeld's telling you
when he was young he did that you'd be
like
whoa and what was that like what did you
think was gonna happen
like i mean dude if hiv aids didn't take
us
out i'm not trying to talk [ __ ] here but
if hiv aids
didn't take us out okay the way that
that was contracted and passed along
through banging and shooting drugs two
of the funnest things to do on the
planet
like like nothing's gonna stop that yeah
if that didn't take us out i think we
should be fine let me shut off my phone
here so it doesn't make those stupid
noises
all right there we go sorry it's all
good
yeah i know what you mean and and it's
funny you said earlier about like not
watching the news
i find myself not watching the news
either because i i i can't trust the
information that i'm getting
and it's it seems to it seems to
politicize
cute it's it's it's like they're uh one
news channel is working for joe biden
the other one's working for trump
and so it's just totally uh i i stay out
of that stuff i've been um
you know i watch a lot of nhl hockey i'm
beyond excited september 10th
the nfl comes back you really think the
nfl is gonna
gonna thrive you think they're gonna be
able to do it you think they're gonna
tell you what i thought fantasy football
is the dumbest thing
silliest thing ever i'm actually going
to do it this year
i want to be that in on it oh wow i love
fantasy i've been playing
i'm the commissioner of my fantasy
football league now for 20 years
that's hilarious well i mean i just
don't like that i don't know
the names anymore like when i was a kid
and i collected football cards i knew
all the names
so i got to get back and the names are
way more syllables
uh than they used to be you know what i
mean
yeah you just be like leon gray
jim plunkett jim joe's leon's
harvey's just simple hard-working names
now they're just like yeah
yeah now that they're they're yeah and
nhl is the same way i was just talking
to burke christian about this nhl once
uh the russians came in and the people
from like sweden and finland i mean i i
mean
come out the name picked up the whole
back goes down the [ __ ] pant lick
is hockey your number one sport is that
your favorite sport
uh yes
you know i i used to talk [ __ ] about
hockey but now i've seen it live a few
times
and it's the most engaging live sport
you could you could you could watch it's
like i don't care and you know what i
love about hockey it doesn't matter what
level it is
like i was in edmonton doing gigs and i
was at the mall and they had that ice
rink
and it was like some high school kids
playing and i found myself being like
wow this is exciting
at any level that's the thing about you
know you know what i mean
yeah and i i i like that most people
don't like it i like that it's sort of
the
uh forgotten of the big four um
you know it's sort of like uh this
underground movie that i love
and other cinephiles really love and uh
you know i still love the nba and stuff
i've been sort of you know i've been
watching out of my peripheral the
celtics but like you know a lot of the
games overlap you kind of have to pick a
dog
in the fight or you need to end your
relationship and watch
both your your hockey and your your
basketball team because you're gonna
have
you know or marry a sports fan i guess
um so i
i know the celtics swept the uh 76ers
which is great and um and my bruins got
their asses kicked last night 701 killed
so you're a hardcore boston fan
it's just your patriots bruins celtics
celtics red sox
red sox that's you true and true oh yeah
i even went to a boston breakers game
way back in the day when the usfl was
there
i think we beat the washington federals
at nickerson field and what's
interesting is that's the first field
the patriots played on
but when they were the boston patriots
way back in the day 1960 they started
out there before they moved over to
fenway park
they played a year in harvard stadium
and then we got
patriot stadium shaffer stadium which
became sullivan stadium
um and now we got gillette
you know i think we're around the same
age and i think i think what's weird
about our age group
is that we lived through like the first
of all the [ __ ] that these kids are
enjoying right now so like we had the
first computer
like you know we had the first like you
know the touch tone phone came
and and then we saw the video game the
video games we saw the
beginnings of the internet like you know
we had all this [ __ ] equipment that
we thought
this i don't know if this is going to be
a thing and now here we are now they
then
but then our our worlds overlap like you
just talked about having trading cards
like kids don't know
with the internet you don't need trading
cards yeah but the
adults ruined football cards and
baseball cards because what happened was
uh people from the 1950s all of a sudden
their baseball cards were worth tens of
thousands of dollars
so then the kids in the 70s like you
should save these these will pay for
your college someday and
and then tops flooded the market because
so many
baseball cards because now they weren't
just being collected by kids
they were being collected by like
professional collector adults
and um then it just got ruined and then
then there were no rare cards because
there'd be nine million pete rose
baseball cards that year
so then upper deck and them had to make
them deliberately
hard to get a few of them made them rare
on purpose
and they hope they just got perverted or
whatever and all i wanted to do was just
buy the complete set
so i could go through them like
multiplication flash cards
dude i used to know the heights colleges
they went i knew all the offensive
linemen i mean i
and year after year after year when i
collected you know there was a few guys
would leave or get traded a few new
rookies if you guys
retire but you still had that core that
you knew
but that's basically google now that's
basically like you go to the team page
and you go oh offensive lineman let me
find out about him now you can find out
like what school he went to you could
find out like
his salary his kids you could find out
so much information now isn't that what
that was you know
do you trust how are you saying you
cherish that before you cherish that way
it was before as
as opposed to all this information now
well i just think i'm stuck in the past
and i
they were like they were mine though
yeah i got you that's what i loved and i
you know laid them out and i'd look at
them and like you know football players
were bigger than life to me like i used
to think their shoulders were that big
when i was a little kid i'd walk around
like this my mother be like what are you
doing i go i want to be a football
player he's like
he's like those are pads and i was like
oh i thought it was like muscles i
thought they were like superheroes so
um you know it's weird
yeah i think any time that's small now
they got real big
into the 90s but i think uh yeah
it's the internet you know is having is
having a lot of positive
um results on as far as kids it's it's
weird
it's not it doesn't feel like there's
scenes anymore it's like the whole world
is like one big scene now but i can just
tell you
having played drums and messed around
with guitar like some of these kids
coming up
because of what they can learn on the
internet yeah man
um and with their god-given talents that
i wasn't blessed with which is why i
became a comedian
this there's some kids out there it's
just like they're
they're as good as some of the guys that
used to put out instructional videos
not the top guys but some of them oh
mid-level guys back in the day when i
buy vhs
instructional tapes it's like what
they're playing what
because they built off all of that
they're they're they're amazing
they're amazing bill bill if i need to
learn something
let's say i'm even something technical
or whatever it is i just go i google it
and then a video comes up and it'll be
like an 11 year old
you know giving an instructional video
about here's how you do this
first you do this and i'm just like wow
this is amazing
you know and then yeah you know so like
and i know what you're saying you can
see
you and you can see the progression it's
like the internet is an amazing place
but of course it has downfalls too but
like
i look yeah but everybody always talks
about the downfalls we all know there's
a bunch of [ __ ] up [ __ ] on there but
like
it's like anything it's like if you use
it in a positive way
yeah um you can you you can interact
with it with whatever talents you have
be it like cooking to like you know
music comedy and you can educate
yourself on stand-up
like um i can't you know you can just
sit there all day i know it's crazy
just just give yourself like a like a
phd and whatever the hell it is you're
trying
um if dudes can do it in prison so like
a dude in prison can come out of prison
with an education
from just books i mean like what what
what are we doing as human beings that
we're not using this valuable source of
all this like endless information that's
on the internet
i mean it's craziness well
because you know there's also there's
also something to be said about trying
to turn your brain off every once in a
while
just watching something stupid watching
some guy in a dirt bike
you know wipe out or something like i i
don't know
um yeah that's me and my girl like i
just i just tell
her when i want to watch something
stupid i go we'll watch whatever you
want to watch and then the next thing
you know it's like beverly hills
housewives is on tv
and i find myself getting lost in these
wretched women
you know what i mean like they're just
like you know what i mean i i i don't
i draw the line on those shows oh you
get it
we had another sit down about that last
night
so you have to have like a a uni a state
of the u like what do you
uh united nations kind of talk with you
and your wife about what you watch on tv
yeah because you know we kind of watch
tv at night and it's just like
we'll get into these good runs of
watching some cool documentaries
and um or a couple of cool movies or get
into a series
but then we you know we always kind of
go back we're like uh we go back to
to use it again she goes back and
the two shows i can't stand shows any
reality show where they're just sitting
there screaming
and yelling at each other and yeah um
i remember even that orange county
motorcycles after a while i got sick of
listening to and argue
it's like i just build the [ __ ] bike
i just want to see you build the bike
i don't need the family drama i feel
like i was dropping in on that
thanksgiving every episode
but um the uh and that
and then those those stupid cooking
shows where you don't learn how to cook
that the competition ones it's just them
like yeah yeah i get
and they and it's just like yeah here's
a styrofoam cup and some sardines make
lasagna
you got three minutes you're like huh i
don't know what to do and then they go
to the guys and guys like yeah
the sardines were overpowering it's like
yeah because i had styrofoam with it
what am i supposed to do and then it
just dude and then they do it with kids
and the [ __ ] kids are crying
sometimes i'm like
like what am i getting out of watching
this i'm just watching people getting in
trouble so
um it's what's funny is my favorite
cooking show of all time
is multo mario mario batali
i never saw that oh man it was great you
know i'm not saying you know
i don't know what he did with the guests
afterwards but when you were watching it
it was what cooking what
is cooking is this great thing it's it's
a one of the nicest things you can do
for somebody you would just have three
three or four friends over and he would
cook them a meal and as he cooked it
he would tell him what part of italy it
came from oh you talk about the
surrounding areas and how you know
you know i don't know so you just want
information you want the information and
how to cut out all your the the other
baggage
get that out of here just show me what
you're doing yeah i want to see somebody
great
doing what they're doing i don't want to
see like
and it's like anything like i i i'm into
a bunch of sh if somebody's great at
what they do i i find it like
captivating like i gotta watch this i
can literally watch those kids that can
solve a rubik's cube in like half a
second
to uh you know somebody building a car
to a great drummer like cooks anything i
love that
you know my my first time ever
interacting with you and i know you're
not even gonna remember this
but it was like after you'd done a half
i think it was a half hour
and it was like it was like at the time
i thought
provocative but i don't wanna that's the
only word i can use right now
and you know and then i hit you up on
facebook being like i love what you were
saying
and like you wrote me right back because
you were like feeling the heat of like
whatever like racial tension or whatever
was going on with whatever you were
saying
and uh you know i just i always thought
about like i was like oh i really like
this guy
like you know how does it feel like
you've become like you literally
are people's favorite comedian like even
amongst people that do comedy
you know when you talk to comedians and
they go like who's your favorite comic
you know
like you're always going to be in the
top three of what people say
right now i mean like that's crazy you
know i
i can even see on your face right now
there's some humility coming on your
face right now but
i mean honestly how does that feel
that's humbling because that's what you
want i feel more than
anything obviously you want to sell
tickets and you want to like
make a living but like to have other
comics
think you're funny and to make another
comedian laugh
is yeah that's sort of the height of the
compliments and um as far as like
all of that other stuff you know i
i have this healthy
ability to block [ __ ] out
so as i've moved up i haven't really
thought about it
and my wife reminds me of that like when
i roll down my window and i yell at
somebody in traffic
and she'll just be like hey stupid
you realize he was you know that that
person could be
somebody who was gonna watch efforts for
family and now they're not
and then i always get such a kick out of
that because i'm so in the moment and
i'm pissed
that like i would that would be funny to
me
if i pulled up at a red light and some
guy cut me off and rolled down his
window
and started yelling at me and i'm like
oh [ __ ] that's you know
right right on the jets right that's my
favorite
well my favorite comic just yelled at me
yes by the way by the way i love that
family by the way i watched that
religiously
well those are the areas that i have to
watch out for but then other than that
i it also took me so long to get where
i'm at
that i can avoid i i
can sort of avoid a lot of the pitfalls
that i saw that made people go up and
then come back down again
which is uh sort of you know settle yeah
man
i have arrived and then you stop working
on your ass
partying you know back in the day it was
you got a sitcom and you stopped doing
stand-up
and i got to see all those guys when
they spit out the other side
with their syndication money and stuff
so they were all right
but they would go down to the club and
it was like you know i
i equate stand up to like music where
every five years
there's there's a change it's like it
went disco to metal
grunt to boy bands and somewhere in
there hip-hop
crossed over into the mains i'm just
talking mainstream white [ __ ] because
that's all i know
hip hop crosses over in the mainstream
um
you know where then it just takes over
the whole countdown to that level i know
there was the run dmc
aerosmith thing so i don't need the
[ __ ] text messages after this
or the emails whatever you call them um
comedies like that and [ __ ] that that
it's weird like rhythms that
flew five years ago are now
corning and because if you're in it
every night and you're down there you
don't notice it suddenly changing and
you subtly change it yeah
and but you have to be you got to be
neck deep in it you got to be working
with younger comics they'll keep you
young
because they're the next kings of the
castle
and they are going to take over because
every generation
you know needs their bands and their
movies and their comedians
so um yeah so i i don't know i i've just
i've seen
a lot of uh looks like uh one of those
heart monitors people's careers
so i don't ever think it's just gonna go
like this
so you know you know i've always wanted
to ask you this though
i mean it's like you you're you're
you're always like you say you don't
care about what necessarily the outside
forces but
you know you're very much like on the
cutting edge you're the things that you
talk about
how you talk about them like one of my
favorite things about you when i'm
watching you
like at the comedy store and you're
working something out you always start
at an
outrageous place you you started out you
started an
outrageous place that makes everybody go
what the
[ __ ] is he about to say about this but
by the time you get to the end
you very much have explained which is
which is the brilliance of your style is
like you go
you make a statement it might rub people
the wrong way and then you explain how
you got there and then we all go
okay i i totally get where he's going
with this now you know what i mean
but like if it works if it does right
but like
do you think that you know but and when
you were coming up i'm sure you were
you you this was what you were doing but
like with the internet
and social media and the cancel culture
and all that
do you think that if you were starting
now
do you think that you could you could
have done it the same
or would you have had a different way of
doing it because
you're talking about such a small
portion
of the population then they just you
know they're brilliant with what they do
they know where to apply
pressure they apply pressure on money
they go after corporations and they make
threats
and corporations they act like the mop
so it's just like oh this guy's a
problem he's more problem than he's
worked
whack him we'll get another guy in there
to collect the numbers you know
so um but because
that's how they do it they appear much
larger
than they are and if i learned anything
this weekend
but you can't believe some of the [ __ ]
that came out of my mouth
one joke in particular that was i would
never do that
where people had phones on and what what
really pains my comedic heart is that it
[ __ ] killed
[Laughter]
got you is that a kill yeah
so um and it was deliberately
offensive and absurd i was talking about
the mass
signs that they had they had these masks
that said be kind with a little heart on
it
and i was just like that sign is so
stupid
because what should that sign appeals to
people
who are already wearing masks that is a
beta
rollover show your belly
mask yeah it's like you want hardcore
trumpsters that think it's [ __ ]
and if you want them to wear masks you
have to speak their language
so the the new advertisement was over
the top
homophobic using homophobia
to make it seem like they were gay if
they were if they didn't wear masks now
i don't
i don't i ain't no queer or whatever and
and but it's just one of those jokes
where now
if somebody were to film it what they do
is they you know they're like surgeons
they take out you use this word this is
a bad word
yeah and you used it and then that means
that you have issues with gay people but
it's not all gay people um because i
because you know what's weird about that
joke i wouldn't do that joke
in front of a mainstream crowd unless
the phones were locked
but i would do it at a gay club right
i know you know what i mean there's a
lot of joke i know exactly what you're
saying part of an all-white crowd
if it's about race but i would do it in
front of an all-black
crowd yes because and it's you kind of
have to be a comedian
to understand that dynamic where it's
just like
because they are all gay because they
are all black or whatever
it's it's um they know that i
there's no way i don't know that right
right right so
it's just white people a lot of times
they're gonna laugh knowing
that you're joking that you're making
fun of the thing not doing it
and then the other way is if
you know there's a few gay people in the
crowd two black people sprinkled in the
crowd or whatever right
and you do the joke and then white
people do that
yeah and then they look at said group
yeah then it just becomes this [ __ ]
pain in the ass
well i mean it's easy to get out of it
the black you feel the white people
looking at you it makes you feel good
dumb [ __ ] but um unfortunately you have
to do that unfortunately it's like
because you're really saying
in your mind you're going in my mind
i'll just speak for me i'm saying
when i say that to a crowd and i see
white people doing that i
there's an anger in me that i get
because i'm just like you don't think
i [ __ ] see these people in the crowd
i'm up here i see all of you you think
that i'm just doing this for you
like the arrogance of white people in
the crowd to think that
we're only speaking to them and then
they have to look around and make sure
hey is everything okay
it's like hey the world don't revolve
around you [ __ ]
look around well this is what's funny
about you is you with just a mustache
how you look you can get away with more
ethnic [ __ ]
than you that that's salt and pepper
beard we'll see all of a sudden
is this guy italian is the uh
egyptian what's going on here yeah but
if you just rock the tom selleck
then you know you come out and do like
you know establish yourself then
there's all of these rules that's also
something that i do love about comedy
but like
it is as a comedian who loves comics it
is kind of painful watching comics
attacking other comics
on social media sometimes and you want
to be like guys guys guys
let's get each other's cell phone
numbers and have it out let's
let's stop the cannibalism here um
you know this this isn't this isn't good
for anybody however having said that
i've made fun of some comedians tweets
on my podcast
i am i am a hypocrite well i mean
i think you know something that you were
just saying that i i i
i feel myself too i i think that i guess
my question i'm trying to ask you is
that
you know i i think that there's a purity
to like doing a joke in a comedy club in
front of people where it stays here
where it's like can we just have this
experience right here
but with social media and so much comedy
on television and youtube and all this
kind of stuff
i think it it dilutes it and it also
takes away from that like hey we're just
having a moment
here i'm saying this joke here just
gotta block that out eric and you just
gotta plow ahead
and and and just that's it you just have
to block because it still is great and
it still is special and it still is
intimate
and it's not like every show you do
somebody's posting clips trying to take
you out
right it's just of course what it's what
they've done is
is they they've instilled this sort of
fear
so that's why
you know my last special
maybe was the way it was because what it
is was it was feeling claustrophobic and
you're trying to push it back out
i think a few of the comics that i'm
really really a big fan of i noticed
that they were going harder
and i think that that is the cure
to this where it's just like you know
the harder they come at you the harder
you got to go on stage
because at the what they're doing
is in my world is unquestionably wrong
and i don't think it's going to stand
the test of time when people look back
and uh you know
i don't know it's like i already saw it
was funny i kind of saw someone
tweeting about nervous about canceled
culture
and it was really ironic because early
on this was a person that was
in their own way helping to build it and
i feel like that monster
has sort of broken out of the yard yeah
yeah
and now it's like it kind you know in
the beginning
it was kind of uh you know political
correctness then the harvey weinstein
thing went down and then the louis thing
went down
and then it just sort of became like
and then and then it was like then they
started going after like
pussyhounds and now they're going after
ellen for being mean
and it's just sort of now it's like yeah
i feel like it sort of broke out of the
castle
and it's just swinging this thing
because i i gotta admit man
out of all the [ __ ] [ __ ] because who
knows what happened it could happen it
could not happen there's not gonna be a
trial
there's no burden of proof that you know
that sounds real
it this one doesn't who knows you know
if you weren't there who the [ __ ] knows
right
but i will say like
that the fact that ellen had to like
apologize
make a public apology or something like
that it's like i never worked for you
yeah yeah i felt like that was like some
in-house locker room [ __ ] yeah man
like all right it got a little sideway
uh maybe i was a little bit of a [ __ ]
and then then i looked like the
executive producers like she's supposed
to be babysitting their behavior
and i don't know but people say oh you
know you set the tone and
which i do believe but like i just
thought that that was a huge ugly mess
that could have been handled
internally if the people that paid ellen
gave a [ __ ]
right because the people that pay the
celebrity that
allegedly acts that way um there's no
way they're not hearing complaints and
if they just ignore it because that's
their show
pony bringing home the [ __ ] trophy
every night then
you know they i don't know well you know
they should come down there and be like
you know you're not the first tv show
that's ever been on here
yeah and you won't be the last so uh why
don't you tone down the uh
[ __ ] behavior a little bit that's all
it takes we don't need to know about it
it shouldn't take
because you know what you know why they
don't care because a show makes so much
money
so they just go hey just do whatever you
do it doesn't matter and it isn't until
like the public or it
is unfortunately until it goes public
that it makes people go
hey uh then that's when they step in
that's why they that's why things yeah
but it's not because the general public
cares though
it's just because they know so now
they're looking at them so now they got
to put on a show like they care about
human beings which they don't it's
chopin
well you know there's no love there's no
warmth this reminds me of my like what
you're saying right now
it just reminds me of my grandmother's
dog my my grandma had this dog named
bruno
and it was the most vicious dog like i
could never be around it
no one could come in the backyard and i
always thought to myself
don't you shouldn't trust this dog and
sure enough that dog bit my grandma when
they got sick
you know and that's what that's the me
too movement and culture and all this
stuff
you the cancer culture and all that like
you say
now it's going to ellen you know and
it's like and then it's going to then
think it's going to start attacking any
like all
powerful women and what what if the
dominoes the next level they go
is then they try to vet annoying people
right
and then it's gonna be uh
wishy-washy people
like i don't know like human beings are
so incredibly flawed like i
i don't um and
i don't think any human being if you're
doing any sort of work on yourself
doesn't look at yourself three years ago
why did i say that why did i do this
four or five years ago how did i think
something like that
yeah it's just unfortunate stand up act
i stunk as a comedian i can't believe
people are laughing at this [ __ ]
it's just like it's such a it's such a
fail-safe thing to do like we're gonna
vet this person
and go back in their life and see if
they ever made a mistake it's like well
yeah
i know [ __ ] i [ __ ] up you know
probably 20 times in the last today
i don't know and i feel like who cares
i'm hey you know what let me i got to
grab a water ahead
bill burr's parched everybody's going to
get some water
[Laughter]
is this your office we're looking at
right now
it's my office slash garage slash drum
room
oh i love it this is this is my part of
the house this is what yeah this is the
every guy's got to have a man cave you
know
it it just keeps the peace you let them
do whatever they want to do in the house
the rest of it is yours
but you gotta have this underneath it or
next to it
and whatever they want to do however
many throat pillows they want to put on
a [ __ ] couch that nobody can sit down
let them do it i just gave up my girl
moved in with me and it's like all my
silverware has been thrown away
you know you know it's all these that's
a good move that's a good single guy
silverware just made me kind of i just i
just gave up
i just like like like the bathroom i
don't even recognize it anymore you know
so like i just i just i i migrated to
the guest bathroom
and i just go okay that this master bath
bedroom bathroom is like
i don't know what happened man i had
this thing that i put the toilet paper
in
next to the thing you know you can so
you can get new
that's gone you know everything on this
counter
gone like i had all these little things
and i just you
you just get to a point where you go all
right give up do whatever you want does
this make you happy
are you happy because if you're happy
great i'm out
you know what i ever wanted was if if uh
how a rodeo clown
shares a bathroom with his girlfriend
or a mime you know yeah it's like you
have to get ready at work there's not
enough room here
that's the reason they have like jack
and jill sinks yeah
but then even then this [ __ ] ends up
like the other day i got some epsom salt
and whatever and a couple other things
for her and all of this [ __ ] went under
my sink
i'm like why is it underneath that she
goes i just thought i'd put it on go
no why is it anything she's like because
there's no room under my mind
that's what they do man and then she she
just
she's on this thing now where she's just
gonna throw things away
you know like if i if she thinks i don't
need it it's gone
and i used to really get like i used to
have this kind of like
without asking you yes without asking me
okay she threw away a little spoon of
mine it was a honey spoon
i called in my honey spoon it's my
little spoon and she was like you don't
need a baby spoon
why do you have a baby spoon and [ __ ] so
we got it like
it's a principal argument you know what
i'm talking about
this is like hey okay don't throw my
[ __ ] away
without asking you got it well you have
to find out why she's doing that
you don't have to but you could because
that could be it is a stupid spoon
or it could be all the way to
uh a jealousy issue and she's worried
that something in here must have come
from another girlfriend
and i need to get rid of all of this
[ __ ] so all of his memories are with me
i think i think you would know that i
think there's a little bit of that
already i
i had an ex give me this blanket and it
has like my name on it you know
and she's like what [ __ ] is trying to
keep you warm you know
you know what i mean it's that kind of
thing so we are working on that i mean
jealous you're like
my mother yeah
yeah that's what you have to do i mean
that's like we just i just don't think
about those kinds of things you know i
just don't think about like
oh did you get that was that a jacket
that your ex-boyfriend used to wear
it doesn't bug me you know i'll be oh
nice jacket you know what i mean oh good
good
good move stealing that from him all
right but you know that's how i think
about it or if it's jewelry that is
another
like oh you that's a nice nice earrings
where'd you get those if you were like
my ex i'm not going to be like
no other man's jewelry is supposed to be
on your ears because i you're with me
now
i don't give a [ __ ] about the past you
know what i mean
i just that's just me so i we're
compromising
you know you've been how long you been
you've been married a long time right
uh seven years oh that's not even a long
time so you're still knee deep in it you
you still haven't figured each other out
yet huh well seven's a big one where
this is where we're supposed to break up
or we're gonna stay together evidently
seven seven year rich um
yeah no we no we get along uh
incredibly well when it's just us and
now that we've had
kids and the stress of that and just you
know the first five years of a kid's
life getting them up and running
it really does a number on
you connecting with the person that
you're with so you you have to make sure
that you're kind of checking in
um as much as you can so uh
you know that's that the talk we had
last night
you know it's like you know you can't
you when you feel yourself growing apart
you got to sit down and talk about it
because i've done that [ __ ]
we both did because we're stubborn where
we were like i'll wait for you to bring
it up first and then that that's a
that's it you're playing russian
roulette with the relationship and it's
no one's going to win that one
do you think that the quarantine has
helped strengthen your relationship
being forced because it did for me like
she moved in because of the quarantine
you know and
it was like fast tracking moving past a
lot of things to be like oh
i can this can work but i'm sure there's
cause you know in china
they said the divorce rate will it went
up like seven seven times
so i know there's a lot of people who
are like oh
i well i gotta get the [ __ ] away from
you you know
there's definitely uh one of the
symptoms of an unhappy marriage is being
a workaholic and burying yourself to
work so maybe if they got taken away
from that
they finally had to address the elephant
in the room but um
no it's been uh it's been everything
it's been good it's been hard
it's been exhausting it's been
like nice like it's kind of been you
know i've been home every day of my
son's life
um i you know i i and you wouldn't have
made that choice right you wouldn't have
made that choice before if like if the
world was i was gonna stay home for the
first two months and but then you know i
you know i got to go make some money to
keep the lights on i would have gone out
on the road
maybe not as much but um
you know i've got i got to do a lot
of dad stuff which
has been awesome you know when i was out
you know when i did the week with
chappelle
you know i you know i hung out late two
nights
and other than that like i was just
getting up early the other five days and
you know going up ice cream and looking
at the cows
feeding the goats going to the
playground
um just walking my kid down the street
just like all kinds of fun stuff like
that where you know they say the cutest
most adorable stuff
and it's just you're just trying to like
savor all of it
as much as you can because you know a
lot of my buddies you know because i
started so late their kids are now
in high school or going on to college
and they're dealing with like this
you know because i know how much i love
my kids and i can't believe it's like
wow they're gonna leave
you know and uh that's uh you know what
fatherhood looks good on you bill i can
tell that this is like
i like you know it is i mean i liked it
this is like the the softer side of bill
burr i like this a lot um
oh yeah it definitely made me see a lot
of my uglier parts because you're like
you know it's weird it's like your
personality
to a kid is contagious it's like a cold
so you gotta you gotta watch you know
what you're doing around them
is that like uh is that what because
when i you know it's funny when i watch
f is for family i kind of feel like yes
this is like sort of
it's a cartoon but you know just hearing
your voice and like
it's like is that show based at all
about like
your own life or like you know is it
like you took some realness
in in in there is that your dad that
you're being
you know what's funny most of a lot of
frank is me
a lot of frank is me and um
some of the cadence and some of the
expressions is my dad
and then there's other elements of him
that's mike price co-creator of the show
um it's his dad it's uh
david richardson joe heslinger there's
so many people emily towers so many
people over the years
helping to you know
just create this guy you know he just
keeps expanding and spending and
spanning so
but um i i you know from day one i
wanted to make sure when i did the
um when i did the show i didn't want uh
you know i didn't want my family members
or my parents to watch it and be
mortified
like i wasn't gonna do that to them it's
just like why would you tell that story
that was private
i know hey here's what my family was
like from my perspective only it's just
not
you know that would be like if you just
accused somebody they didn't get a trial
and they lost their whole life well yeah
which seems to happen every [ __ ] day
now sorry
that's a little heavy-handed on that one
but as you're doing frank do you find
yourself like if you ever do you ever
watch it and go
oh i got to make sure i'm really not
like this with my kids
[Laughter]
uh oh yeah yeah yeah the screaming and
yelling and flipping out which which i
have
dialed down
like so i i think 70 percent
um because the great thing is my
daughter's not
afraid of me so if i start to lose you
know when i lose it over this stupid
[ __ ] computer something like that and
she'll just be another room be like
don't scream like that
and i immediately go you're right buddy
sorry
and then you're coming down why you yell
why are you yelling like that i'm just
like
i've been patient i got frustrated with
the computer but you know and she's
houston when she was real little she'd
be like daddy it's gonna be okay it's
gonna be okay because we used to say
that there when she was crying so she
would literally be
talking to me like i was a little man
like she was
like that's great and the irony was i
was behaving like a little kid
so um and i did need to grow up so
um that's really helped and i just think
the older
my kids get and the more aware
they are the more that they're going to
help me to kind of get rid of that
hopefully but i can't say for good
because i am who i am but like
i i definitely you know any
the big difference that i made
is that uh
that i guess with my [ __ ] is you can
totally come up to me and say that i
[ __ ] up
and i i will uh i will agree with you
and i will apologize and then i will say
that i will work on it
and that gives somebody like
you they're being heard they're they're
told that they're right
and that you are wrong you apologize and
it gives it sort of
gives them closure as opposed to this
pain or hurt or anger
that turns into anger that they carry
around which is what the [ __ ] i am
but do you but do you think that i know
see i'm
i cannot i feel you man because i'm
feeling this way and i feel like because
of the quarantine and
so at first for me not having this like
creative outlet
that is so what i realized going on
stage every night was also a way to
release
a lot of yes a lot of that you know
and you know and and and the you know
the great thing too is that
we could obsess about the things we hate
because we could talk about them at
nauseum every
single night but you can't do that with
like your wife because you're gonna be
like i heard this story already you told
me this yesterday i'm out
you know and again i missed validation
from the crowd where i would say
something and they would laugh and you'd
be like so you
get this so i'm not crazy i miss that
yeah
validation i mean there's definitely
sometimes that laugh like you're
laughing because what you said was so
nuts
but there's a few things when i would
specifically [ __ ] about something going
on in my life some
you know man woman [ __ ] and i always
loved looking out at the crowd
depending on which side i was doing it
from and seeing the laughter and the
acknowledgement and just like all right
they're going through it too
i'm not crazy blah blah blah blah
and it just it you know that connection
is is uh you know yeah you know i'm
definitely
missing that yeah i just that's i
totally get that and i
but but at the same time i can't also
appreciate
you know what this quarantine has done
is like made me
have to reevaluate why i feel the way i
feel like
do i need to do i need to like
that's the only way to like release
tension and stuff it's making me really
grow
this is what has happened i mean i feel
like now like
every year the whole world should shut
down you know i mean you know
you know what i mean like i think we
need like two weeks where the whole
world goes you have to stay at home for
two weeks
i mean it's better for the environment
it's like this is different you know the
ozone's doing great right now
you know what i mean oh it is no it
wouldn't you know
um i don't know
big problems out there man there's
really big problems out there
with that uh the
the downfall of us was the creation
of corporations and how they operate and
the fact that they make so much money
now that like
politicians are just slaves to their
will
and they can just finance their whole
campaign
and they just own them they just all own
and if they're not owned then they're
called socialists or communists or crazy
people
um on both sides
you know i liked ross perot back in the
day i liked ralph nader i liked bernie
sanders
i mean i even enjoyed trump for a little
while
when he was calling out i've given money
to every candidate up here
and and one guys we didn't give money to
me and all the rest of them shut up it
was it was
it was hilarious until he got elected
right and then when he got elected i'm
like i already maybe surround himself
with some people but
like um my biggest thing with that guy
is just the lack of leadership
and i got so much out of what if not if
you read that article seinfeld wrote
in the new york times i didn't see that
one some comedy club owner was
leaving and seinfeld basically wrote
like a newt rockne speech
to new york city that i was able to
apply like this is new york man we've
been through worse we're gonna come
around if you want to leave
basically was saying the guy was weak
for leaving and um
and just reading it was like this is
what has been missing
yeah yeah in all of this where all the
left is doing is blaming trump
and all trump's doing is blaming that or
the it's the chinese virus that just saw
this finger pointing [ __ ]
the guy dropped the pass at second down
get back in the huddle we're gonna get
him on this one
yeah you can spend the whole [ __ ] 30
seconds we got here screaming at the
[ __ ] wide receiver and making sure
everybody knows that he dropped it
and he just [ __ ] with your stats it's
just like for [ __ ] sakes people
grow a dick stop peeing in your pants
stop [ __ ] pointing at people [ __ ]
let's all get on the same page and
[ __ ] knock this thing out
and get back to our lives you know i
always feel that i always feel the same
way about whoever's in
office i feel like there's a lack of
leadership
when these two sides are fighting so
much
like who the who could bring
like some of them together who can you
know it's it's
it's the thing that has been going on
since bill clinton
like the first george bush herbert
walker was the last guy
i felt that was allowed to be president
i mean you're always going to get
attacked from the other side but
yeah when bill clinton
got impeached for lying under oath is
what they got him on
over his extracurricular activity that
was
a watershed moment and we went from that
to george bush stole the election to
obama wasn't
born here to to trump everything
and it's just like how the [ __ ] i mean
that's the guy leading the country how
the [ __ ] is he supposed to get anything
done
if he has to spend the entire day
under attack from his fellow countrymen
yeah
his criticism and then this just
undermining somebody
and um you know
these like i said these are big problems
way bigger than me i don't know how to
fix them but like i don't think
it helps anybody um because you know
everybody's looking at oh like on the
left right now it's like oh joe biden
gets in
it's like then the right's gonna attack
him his heart as you guys have been
attacking
trump and he's not gonna be able to get
anything done and at some point
we're gonna have to the hatfields and
mccoys have to shake hands
and be like all right you killed 18 of
our guys maybe we got 17 or 19 of yours
the [ __ ] is over let's let's
try to work to i don't know that's why i
i i commend people
that can sit down and watch the news um
day in and day out i don't know how you
do it i don't know either
impressed i tried i tried i i would i
used to do this thing where i would flip
between like cnn msnbc then i would flip
over to fox just to see
[Music]
i'm telling you man i remember this is a
real telling moment for me when i
realized it's like doing a line of coke
after being
after you're drinking all night nobody's
like trying to even you're trying to
level up trying to level
i remember this one it was like during
katrina okay the katrina uh
hurricane in new orleans i'll never
forget this
you turn on cnn msnbc
and they made it seem like george bush
caused katrina you know like it's just
that was
all the talk then you flip over to the
other one
and it was it just was a completely
different skew
and i thought to myself well where's the
news
like where's the information where's the
then you can't find it at all and then
you started to like see that this is
just a thing that's
that's been going on even before because
we come we come from a time where there
was only three stations
and you turn on the news that you know
you turn it on at eight or ten
and you believed everything you heard on
the news right
we've come to find out that we should
have never believed anything that was on
the news
or we should at least look at it back
then
it's bad it was back then you at least
had there was there was
rules of um ownership of media
was regulated yeah i remember back in my
college days communication major there
was something there was a rule of sevens
and no one person could own any
combination of seven radio stations tv
stations newspapers magazines
in one market because they understood
the danger
of one person doing that um
because they could control public
opinion they could literally control
what information you got what
information you didn't get
how it was presented and over the years
through just money money money throwing
it at these guys
everything became deregulated from banks
to ownership of media
and now everybody's at their throats and
i don't know how to undo it i don't
think you can undo it so
what you have to do is an individual
you have to sort of either rise above it
or step to the outside of it
and be like i am not going to let this
[ __ ]
control my emotion i had a great
conversation with the guy when i was in
uh yellow springs i'm a mass guy he
wasn't a mascot
and we just agreed to disagree
i stayed six feet away from him i said
let's change the subject all right we
just talked about other [ __ ] i talked
about ohio
and he was moving to dayton we had a
great conversation and i really enjoyed
talking to him
as a person and i was able you know i
didn't agree with what he was doing he
didn't agree with what i was doing but
we had a nice
civil conversation and um
i don't know i i think well that's
what's understood
well yeah but i mean who stops at a
civil conversation when you've got 700
channels
of people yelling at each other titties
car chases
the fast and the furious 59 right like
who's gonna
stop and watch a civil conversation yeah
i think
it's it's all making noise and waving
your hands now yeah i totally agree but
it's like you know the corporation part
of it is like
you know this is why i'm not for
gestures anymore it's like symbolic
gestures uh
it's not gonna make change you know it's
like the money money's the only thing
that really moves anything
you know it's like with donald sterling
when he was on it when he owned the
clippers
the guy's been racist for 30 years he's
had he said he's been on trial for a
bunch of things
about his uh you know what is how he did
he
worked his apartments and who he allowed
to live in his different places but
whatever
no one cared you know the clippers were
making money and it it we just
but once once those corporations said
yeah we're gonna pull out of the staples
center
if uh this because of his behavior
that's when they went okay he's got to
go you know
yeah so it's the same thing with this
now you know it's like
yeah it's great have black lives matter
on the floor all right all the jersey
stuff it's just symbolic [ __ ] that
you know it doesn't affect real change
you know so because
well they i i think the fact that they
they
didn't play those games in milwaukee or
the game in milwaukee
um that affected money and advertising
and all of that and i
i think that i really think that that's
gonna
uh i think that's going to change i
think it's it's got to go through this
really
horribly ugly period but i think it
comes out the other side and i think
um a lot more white people
you know understand as much as you can
understand as a white person to be
honest with you because
you just you're not living that
experience so man you know i can sit
there and listen to a thousand people
that fought in a war
and listen to all of their stories i
don't know what it's like to be in that
foxhole
here in that shell coming in wondering
if this is the end of your life so
um but i just think people have a lot
more informed about stuff like that and
uh
hopefully you know you know cops are
taking a beating right now like they're
all bad you know
yeah it's kind of like comics where they
always act like we have we go to a party
and put a lampshade on our head and
won't shut the [ __ ] up yeah yeah
or right now if you're a male comic uh
you're you're a terrible person
you know yeah you're a rapist uh
whatever the [ __ ] you yeah and it's kind
of like
that that's just kind of it's i always
call that the jerry springer effect
where you get defined
by the worst like i know a guy used to
be a cop and when
you know he was talking about what how
that whole thing went down in milwaukee
he goes those guys they're idiots he
goes you had all these other
options and how he was trained he said
you use this expression left of bang you
stay left of bang
which the bang meaning literally using a
gun or or
whatever it escalated to a violent thing
it's like martial arts you know what i
mean if you can avoid the fight avoid
the fight
so i will tell you something that was
astoundingly
[ __ ] up that when
you know the video came out of them
shooting that dude in the back
seven times this guy's put out a video
goes maybe well maybe it's because of
this
and he just shows some random black guy
fighting with cops
and i i was just thinking like this guy
is so racist he doesn't
he doesn't think he just made a point
yeah it's like
all right so i can find a rant i can
find a video of a random white guy
fighting with cops does that mean now
that they can shoot you in the back
yeah you know you're on our you know you
can be paralyzed like
did i need to take a clip of charles
manson be like all right now it's open
season on white people
like like but the thing about it is is
that guy
is so down that
hole that he he thought that was like a
mic drop the way he presented it was
just like yeah
and it's like it was astoundingly
uh i don't know i don't even bill i know
exactly listen
if people would just have a reasonable
discussion about
this issue i'm totally with you i was
talking about this yesterday
and i'm so glad you used the martial
arts example
because if you are trained in martial
arts
if you're a trained because you're then
you're you're a trained killer
you know and you're at a bar
and a person that gets drunk
starts acting up if you get into a fight
with that person
and destroy that person people might be
like
hey you [ __ ] that guy shouldn't have
been drunk but no they're still gonna be
like yo
come on man you you're a [ __ ] black
belt and whatever why would you beat up
that dude
you could have handled that differently
to me that's the cops
and so what it is is they don't realize
that they are
trained that they are they are a lethal
weapon
in that situation where they reach for
their gun so
everything that happens up to that point
is the
is the problem the lack of training the
whatever is going on we're like how did
you let that situation escalate to
this point and there is the other side
too i can tell you
a job i wouldn't want to do is pull over
a [ __ ] car on the side of a highway
yeah first of all with all the people
texting you can just get clipped and
dive there
or worse [ __ ] survives getting run
over by a car doing you know all that
that speed i would not want to go up to
a car
not knowing what the [ __ ] was in there
and i can't see and i got
kids and [ __ ] like i don't think enough
times
they address how scary that is
for the officer so whenever i get pulled
over
my move was always to have my hands like
yeah i used to do this i would sit like
this
when they would come up and i'd wait
till they get to the window and then
slowly go down like that and be all
right is it okay if i do this
is it okay if i do that because i want
that guy
chill i don't want him like
i don't want to come off as shifty um
but it's a dangerous job it is a
dangerous job
for the thing about it is too is that
there's all of these problems in society
that these cops are then
like we let them deal with it
like the fact that we've we've cut all
the funding from mental health and all
that and they just send these people
out and close the street and these cops
have to go up and they don't know you
know is this a drug addict with the
[ __ ] needle that's hiv positive is
going to stick me
like i think it's very easy to arm chair
quarterback a lot of this stuff but like
what you're saying is
there needs to be a discussion where
both sides yes
non-cops and cops can just say
say like okay this is what i'm going
through when i'm walking up to a car
and then the person pulled up this is
what i'm thinking when you're coming up
to the car
and get that information out there
without being like
you know black people are prone to
violence exactly
or uh cops are a bunch of murderous
fascists but
it's there's examples
on the whole spectrum and you have to
you know and i don't think that that
should just be the responsibility of
the cops and the people that are being
pulled over like it
you know i i don't you know i don't know
like i always feel guilty doing like a
benefit as a comic
that you get credit that you did
something it's like i went down and i
live my dream for free
tonight that's my big sacrifices i
didn't make my [ __ ]
50 bucks to do this spot how many times
you've done a benefit like what does
this benefit about again yeah i mean you
put me down
and you it's a lot of times you still
get paid so you're just kind of like
well this is just a paid gig like what
am i you know
but then there's people like you know
steve simone who actually get involved
yeah and it's all the earth that guy yes
and like doesn't just go like oh you
know [ __ ]
help out homeless people hashtag i'm
woke
he doesn't just tweet about it he
actually
does stuff and like i have lazily
through his work
been able to help people i
he's like uh a headhunter of homeless
people you know what i mean back in the
day when they were fighting they would
find people
uh for jobs these bum headhunters back
in the day uh
i've been able to use like the work that
that guy's doing and like and for
a long time i've been wanting to get
involved
in um for years like a decade i was like
you know what i'm gonna find some sort
of uh
battered women's shelter thing and
anonymously
i want to try and help out uh any way
that i can
and you know there's always some stupid
thing i have to do and i don't get
involved so
how much can i really sit back and be
like your [ __ ] problem is
yeah yeah [ __ ] senate in the house
with the democrat conservative
republican liberals need to [ __ ]
it's like what the [ __ ] are you doing
yeah it's i know exactly what you mean
man it's a tough
and that's why i say like more
reasonable conversations need to be
happen like you know you could look at
that situation with that jacob what
the jacob black or whatever the guy's
name was that uh you know that
unfortunately
got shot in that situation and you can
look at this and
and all you have to do is just
reasonably look at it and be like
there's issues here that the cops could
have dealt with this differently
and there's issues where we you know we
go hey we have to somehow find out what
was going on in this guy's life i mean
it doesn't always have to be like one
side is right one side is wrong and
argue about it
that's why i look at it and i just say
to myself hey you know
like what where's the training you know
where are like
the cops coming into the neighborhoods
and getting to know the people in the
neighborhoods where the
the people in the neighborhoods go like
hey who are these cops i mean they are
people too like you're saying and i just
think that it's okay to have a
reasonable talk about it without it
being like
some sort of finger pointing you know
and i know what you mean like i just i
did a thing for the chp
and they gave me this plaque and so i
just i did that
i keep the plaque in my car so like if i
ever get pulled over and like they ask
me for my insurance
i want to like you know i want
i want to go to the glove compartment
and that plaque falls out and i just
wait
oh man my chp plaque
man like you know sorry interrupt that's
the difference
between our experiences is to me i'm
like
yeah where can i hang this on the wall
you're going out and getting one of
those fat boy gold chains yeah dude i'm
wearing that [ __ ] when i drive
like hello officer yeah yeah i'm like
you see my uh what i mean it is a
different experience like you know
even for me i'm upper middle class when
i grew up you know
i always have a story about the cops i
got pulled over when i was like
17 18 years old and let me tell you what
i did
i pulled i got pulled over and i
literally got out of the car
i got out of the car and i i was walking
over to the police
car to find out hey guys what's up
because i didn't know
but you know what i know about these two
white cops
that they were well trained
and they assessed the situation like
this they looked at me
and i was not a threat and they they go
hey you know they got me they didn't
handcuff me but they held my hands
behind my back
they checked the car and then they were
like hey you know you got to slow down
or whatever they were telling me and
they let me go
and i always remember that i was like oh
that was great and then later
you look at the news and you see some
things happen happening you go whoa
that could have went a completely
different direction and so
i always i'm always thankful that those
two particular cops
they did they weren't trigger happy or
they weren't scared or they
whatever it was in their ability to be
like
assessing the situation so when i always
think about what happens with the cops i
always think
i always go to from my own experience
these particular cops weren't ready for
this situation
and to me that's the problem because you
know what i can't stand when people give
these
arguments like that guy you were talking
about is they go
well you know for some reason people
want
the the person that the cops were called
for
the reason why they needed to be called
then they want that person to somehow
act
reasonable this person was out of
control that's why the cops were called
so now that the cops are here you all of
a sudden want this person
who's obviously needs to be arrested or
whatever you want this person now to be
like
well now i'm going to act right because
the cops are here no that's why the cops
needed to be called
so that's why it's a dangerous job it's
not you're not supposed to be judge and
jury
you're supposed to be enforced the law
you know
and but and so somewhere along the way
that training for that i don't know if
it's enough
i don't know man that's just my theory
about it
well yeah i mean i mean it's beyond
my brain how you fix it because
uh you know the world is a dangerous
place
and if those guys let their guards down
their life can end
so i mean just being in that mindset is
just would just be stressful
and like you know it's like they're
going to [ __ ] war every day and like
um you know there's a lot of white
people that
you know they talk a good game and they
can hashtag
and call themselves woke which is one of
the funniest things to me
ever yeah the most ridiculous yeah yeah
two other yeah
the latest thing that white people stole
was woke and i loved that they were
still not now they're calling themselves
that because i'm like woke awoke
signaler
and the latest thing too is my favorite
thing is i like
white women calling other white women
karens
so like that's the way to take the word
and now i have it and you're a karen and
then you're saying that
that i'm not one because i'm saying that
and it's just like no wait a minute wait
a minute like you
like this is a word black people came up
people color came up with this [ __ ]
this is like their [ __ ] and you're just
taking it
and and now you're gonna use it so you
can get you so you can divorce yourself
from from i don't know maybe some
criticism you need to hear
i don't know listen i'm not with i can't
stand the term woke
to me woke is for people that don't have
the words to articulate their position
they just use the word woke because it
can be used on both sides
if you're for abortion you could be like
i'm pro-life you know why
because i'm woke i'm pro-choice you know
why because i'm woke it works for both
sides
yeah it's all dumb i do like the the
schoolyard name-calling
he's a chad she's a carrot you know
you're a baby
yeah and all this all of that [ __ ] is
just like you guys are
you guys all sound like [ __ ]
six-year-olds like that it sounds like
like
yeah like maybe a little older than that
reminds me of when i was in second and
third grade
when you tag somebody they got the
cooties yeah and you just run away
you're you're yeah yeah and then like
but it's not real you know but you know
as a kid you think like oh my god
there's cooties on me
what do i do and it's like no you you
can't just bestow cooties on someone you
know it's like so
you could call someone whatever they
want but it's like i i don't know i feel
bad for all the real karen's out there
like all those women who are actually
named karen like
you know what it's like it's it sucks
for them
you know what i mean what are they
supposed to do with their life
yeah there's chads and brads and karen's
and i don't know but you know what
the thing about it is is it will become
passe like i don't think that you know
it just slang comes and goes or whatever
yeah man hey look great that's so great
about the word [ __ ] is it it's
staying power exactly no vulgarity
states but slang you know [ __ ]
i love all those spawn trucking jive
turkey yeah
that all going away then yeah you want a
sucker from uh
the um i used to love suck you a suck
you all
sanford and son my favorite line from
stanford the sun she said you like a
lollipop
a all-day sucker you know that that's
old school they just don't do that
anymore everything gets so personal
i love dan esther yeah and esther was
the best man there's no characters like
that anymore
fred sanford you old she just would go
off on yeah man
they were so mean to each other
that kind of you know what's funny like
the the tv that we grew up on
could never be made today man they just
you look back on some of these things on
tv land or i go on hulu and i look at
some of these old shows
and i'm like i don't know if this situ
this this situation
would be allowed to be on tv right now
just the way
the way the culture is but you know
things come in waves some of that is
good and some of it's bad because
there's definitely some [ __ ] that i've i
watch a lot of me tv
and there's definitely a lot of male
female [ __ ] where it's just like
that is making me uncomfortable yeah
yeah yeah yeah
you know it's funny my girl likes
watching i love lucy
so i'm watching you know and i go oh
that
like i don't know if this even in i love
lucy there were some situations where
she's always getting into something
where
a guy thinks that you know she's into
him and he's kind of coming on to her in
a creepy way
and i just go damn this is
like i don't know if this would fly
right now i don't i don't know if uh
you know people you know you know what i
mean so i don't know man
it's you know yeah we can't solve the
world in one podcast we can't solve the
world's problems in one podcast but what
we can do is just
you know have a great conversation
that's what we can do
that's what we could do we could just
have good conversations and laugh listen
man i want to keep you i really
appreciate you coming
on you literally just you're one of my
favorite comics and i'm not just saying
that
like like you know if i think to the
comedy store there's very few comics
that i go oh
oh who's on and i go in and watch and i
don't just watch just to
as a as a fan i just watched as like i
say what i said earlier is i
i i take from you the idea of being like
here's my premise and let me give me an
opportunity to prove
what i'm saying and i i appreciate that
you're doing that and i want you to keep
doing that
well eric i'm a woke comedian and the
way i do things
oh right back at you dude you're one of
the hardest guys to
fall do when you get when they get into
you it's just
it changes my set like well i guess i'm
not opening with that new joke
i got to do something proven yeah
i always like i always like when you say
that i hear you i hate because you don't
know i hear you bitching sometimes like
this guy [ __ ] he should be going last
why
am i i know cause that that's what ends
up once people
like like your [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
hilarious you i remember oh my god i
used to always have to go on after dalia
i remember crystalline i had going after
that guy i felt like three weeks
straight
and i felt myself starting to not like
him and i was like nah nah now
get yourself in check this is a kid
coming up who's [ __ ] crushing it and
uh you need to respect that and
you know you would you know hopefully i
was doing the same thing and i i
uh you know the uh thank god i was older
when i met him because the younger me
when i was all insecure yeah i'd be like
why don't always have to fall yeah
yeah we're big on excuses man i just
comedians are just you know what's funny
if people don't understand about us you
know we don't even like to admit it but
we're some of the most sensitive people
in the world and the reason why we're
sensitive we have to be sensitive
because that's how we tap into how we
feel about these issues
that's how we tap into like this is what
this joke's going to be about and i'm
trying to move the crowd in this
emotional way the only way to really do
that
is to be sensitive to that it's not a
weakness
and then and then you you spend the
first 20 years pretending you're not
sensitive exactly
exactly you have to pretend like you
said that to me i tell you to go
[ __ ] yourself all right [ __ ] my dick and
i do another joke about it
yeah yeah and secretly you go home and
your girlfriend has to listen to it for
three days
i mean they couldn't hear what i was
saying yeah
and now we now we do that and now comics
are doing that and they're looking at
their phone
they're on their phones looking at their
twitter just like i can't believe that
person is saying this about me they
don't even know me then we want to
engage
and it just turns into a whole thing but
just own being sensitive and vulnerable
like that's and then by the way your
last special like i love the first part
of your special you address you were
addressing what was going on in society
and then it was almost like a second
special because you got really
you when you started talking about
yourself and your family it was a whole
different tone
and like i say i'm glad your kids are
changing you i i really feel
i feel it in this conversation about
like you know you're just you know we're
still evolving even at our in
you're in our 40s evolving as a human
being and i think that's a great thing
to see man and i appreciate you
all right i appreciate you too man thank
you so much
and uh i'll see you in a parking lot
near you
coming to a parking lot near you man i
love it man thanks a lot buddy i
appreciate it
you